your family asks you about the record
what's what is your explanation for how
are you sort of coming to terms with
this if you can just I mean all of
Canada in the world or your fans are
through there having you how are you
talking about the record describe it
just down the barrel going like throwing
my call to join for just $1.99 you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what would 2001 Pete think of the way
you're writing today scary laugh I don't
want to know that's a peep
what would he think I think this is a
record that would probably what we
couldn't have written you know ten years
ago yeah the subtlety would have been
lost on me this record to me feels like
like like Larry David isms or yeah yeah
I would not have been able yeah I
couldn't like that was the thing that I
would not have been able to make it's
super funny because it's I mean you talk
to subtlety I'm like this is so much
angrier than than the stuff we wrote you
know in 2005 but it's very subtle anger
[Music]
it is almost at a point now where you
can't not have hues as a band you're
expected to be both expect to be the
rock star you're also expected to be
voice right do you get into that
lyrically on the record I don't think
that this record does someone asked me
the other day they were like this is it
it's like you're an American Idiot and I
was like I don't think that it is our I
know it's not our birthday because I
think the world is at a vastly different
place
we're in a period of authenticity and
our people appreciate anticipate so I
think that like whatever your views are
are your views and you should just like
I think there's nothing worse than if
you sit there like kind of cover up your
views or try to ride the middle that's
not gonna work for you that's what they
would tell you to do though that's what
they told guys in your position to do
don't pick a side say that you know
don't be I thought that was right right
now and it doesn't work right now no it
doesn't work to me this record speaks or
the attempt of who this record speaking
to is like I have a nine year old I
think that this generation is the
generation that will maybe truly move to
real equality and real ideas and real
because I think that they're further
they're so far removed from it that
maybe that's then that's who I'm trying
to talk to because that's like my only
percent I'm like how do we stop all this
stuff from happening we talked to these
kids who are going to actually make the
chain
[Music]
do you have songs in the catalogue that
you still play live that are just not
you anymore in in some ways yeah I mean
it's weirder for me because because I
have the benefit of the separation from
the lyrics you know I sing them but I
didn't write them
I was always kind of adopting Pete's
character when I was singing them anyway
so I'm so I'm still getting in the head
of you know of like 20 year old Pete and
going this is crazy wild you know